abone ol
[Alkış]
[Müzik]
Bu
konuşmanın başlığı Siz hiç İlham Perisi
gördünüz mü Biz o konuda çok şanslı bir
toplumuz milletiz Biz ilham perisinin
sadece görmüyoruz onu aynı zamanda
yaşıyoruz onu hissediyoruz onu Hatta
duygusuz adeta bizim için kültürel bir
kot haline gelmiş durumda
şimdi sabahleyin bu konuşmayı yapacağım
öğrenince Türkiye'nin böyle dünya
çapında önemli bir sözcük aldım Bütün
zahmet paran bizim için bir 50 saniyelik
kayıt yapıp gönderdi bir onu dinleyelim
ilan pirimiz görelim
abone ol
[Müzik]
var mı
[Alkış]
abone ol
[Müzik]
mi
Evet Aslında
bu da dün bu saat itibariyle başka bir
şey konuşacaktım konuşacağım konu Kripto
paraların Davranış Bilimleri ydi Kripto
paraları teknik kısmıyla kim kazandı kim
kaybetti çok ilgilenmiyorum Ama onun
Davranış Bilimleri gerçekten çok özgün
bir konu belki raporu denk gelmişsiniz
dir dünya ekonomik forumu'nun bu yılın
başında geçen sene dair yayınladı bir
rapor vardı rapor enteresan the
Türkiye'ye kriptopara sahipliği
konusunda dünyada dördüncü Avrupa'da
birinci Şimdi bizden önce kimler var
diye baktığınızda bir sırada Nijerya var
ikinci sırada diyet nam3 sırada
Filipinler var Eğer Nijerya Filipinler
ve bir etme mı dünyada teknolojiyi
kullanan ve gelecek Entegrasyonu en
yüksek olan ülkeler olmadığını
düşünüyorsa ki düşünüyoruz de demek ki
orada Başka bir sosyolojik yönelim var
Dolayısıyla ve yorumlamak Türkiye
sosyolojisi hakkında bize pek çok
verecekti ama derken ne oldu işte iki
gün önce Samsun'daki onun anısına
yapılan saldırıdan sonra ben texte ki bu
18 dakikalık hakkımı bu konuşmadan yana
kullanmak istedim ve günümüze en yakın
görüntüleriyle Gerçekten renklendirilmiş
harika görüntülerle de onu bir kez daha
arka tarafta Yaşayalım istedim konuşma
boyunca bir ilerleyecek Aslında
bakıldığında olayın kendisini çok da
önemli bulmadım
alışmak iyi olur Ama bir şey alıştık
farkındaysanız ülkede ne kadar bir
karmaşa dönüyorsa işte arka tarafta
zamlar çeşitli siyasal tartışmalar
duruyorsa genelde çok alıştığımız konu
Atatürk'ün ya bir üstüne ya heykeline
bir saldırı gerçekleştirir ya da
siyasilerden birinden böyle İrrasyonel
bir deme çıkıyoruz ve enteresan bir hal
alır bu
Fakat bunun bir de başka bir tarafı var
Acaba böyle birşey iyi bir sonucu olur
mu Bence iyi bir sonucu oluyor ki şöyle
bir şey oluyor biz mesela mm boyunca
Atatürk'ü daha çok anlamaya kendi
duygularımızı sosyal medyadan diğer özel
konuşmalarımızı daha çok ifade etmeye
başladık Belki de tam tersi bir sonuç
doğuruyor dur Ama diğer taraftan işim
biraz bilgi felsefesi ne bakalım bu da
önemli Atatürk zaten çok özel bir akıl
Sizce Atatürk'ün büstü heykeli biblosu
Posteri afişi ne kadar Atatürk için
önemlidir ki biz bu tür gerçekleştirilen
olaylar üzerine Acaba ne kadar dertlenme
liyiz diye kendisine başvuruyu istedim
birkaç tane sözünü sizi tekrar diyeceğim
Bence önemli ne diyor Atatürk diyor ki
büyük ölülerin diyor matemle ihtiyacı
yoktur diyor Onların fikirlerini
anlaşılmasını ihtiyacı vardır diyor ya
da bir başka çok iyi bildiğimiz sözünde
Benim de 101 göremeyebilirsiniz
görmeyeli bu ama beni hissettiğinizde
beni anladığınızda Zaten amaç hasıl
olmuş olur diyor zaten vakaya böyle
bakan bir insanın
heykeline yapılan saygısızlık urgan
bağlamak ya da ona pranga vurmaya
çalışmak gerçekten çok amaçsız bir durum
gibi gerçekleşiyor Ve ben bunu bir kaç
tane kavram üzerinden size paylaşmak
istiyorum çünkü benim temelde Atatürk
öğretilerini ilişkin on yıllardır
yanlışlar yaptığımızı düşünüyorlar
semantik böyle anlamsal yanlışlar
özellikle Atatürk pedagojisi yani
Çocuklar ve gençler için Atatürk'ü
anlamada ve anlatmakta çok ciddi
problemler çektiğimiz düşünüyorum
Atatürk'ü bizim algılayış biçimimiz
enteresan bir süper kahraman bir Marvel
karakteri gibi Yenilmez düşmez asla asla
ya o süper kahraman niteliklerini
dışında davranmaz adeta onu Muzaffer
oluşu kendini gerçekleştiren da gayet
gibidir gibi anlatırız ama Atatürk
Aslında böyle bir adam değil Hayatın
hepimiz çok iyi biliyoruz on Yıllar
Boyunca Aslında
çaresizliklerle mücadele etmiş pek çok
kez yenilmiş ve e Muzaffer olduğu konuda
Aslında genç Türkiye Cumhuriyeti kurmak
olmuş bu genç Türkiye Cumhuriyeti eski
ya da yeni değil Türkiye Cumhuriyeti ve
ilelebet yaşayacak olan cumhuriyeti
kurması Aslında onun Muzaffer duruşun en
güzel ifadesi bakın 7 yaşında yetim
kalan sekiz yaşında okuldan alınan 10
yaşında şiddet görüp okuldan tekrar
alınan 24 yaşında tutuklanan 27 yaşında
en büyük rakibi bir kahramankent kendisi
hiç önemsenmeyen 37 yaşında hakkında
dava açılan iki ay yalnız başına
hastanede yatan 38 yaşında Suriye'ye
gönderilen 39 yaşında idam cezasına
çarptırılan Atatürk'ten 542 yaşında ise
genç Türkiye Cumhuriyeti kurdu Peki
Acaba onun heykeline yapılmış bir
saygısızlık bir urgan atmak ya da ona
pranga vurmak Onun değerini bizim
gözümüzde değiştirir mi ya da böyle bir
şey Mümkün müdür diye birkaç kavram
üzerinden şimdi Birkaç hikayelerde Ball
iyi bir takım anlatımlar
gerçekleştireceğimiz ee ee Atatürk
gerçekten bakıldığında
olağanüstü bir cesaret timsali O kadar
cesur bir karakterden söz ediyoruz ki
bir başka büyük isim dünya tarihinde
Mamak bagandi oyuncusuz hatırlarsınız
Ben İngilizlerin Tanrı olduğunu
zannediyorum diyor ta ki Atatürk onları
yeni ne kadar
bakın Türkiye tarihinde 16 tane
imparatorlukları devlet kurmuş bu
tarihte Savaş hileleri çok meşhurdur onu
cesaretine Delal edilecek çok güzel var
mevcut anlatacağım Büyük Taarruz öncesi
Atatürk Ankara'da bir çay partisi
veriyor Bu da o meşhur Savaş
hilelerinden biri çünkü hemen ertesi gün
eski Türk savaşı taktiklerinden biri
kullanılacak ve Kurt Kapanı denilen bir
baskın gerçekleştirilecek
ve baskın planı alırken kurmaylarından
pek çoğu itiraz ediyor Hatta bunlardan
Yakup Şevki Paşa paşam bunu yapmayalım
Eğer bu Harekat başarısız olursa sizi de
asarlar bizde askerlerde Atatürk'ün Buna
da cevabı şu oluyor paşam Sizlerde
etmeyin sorumluluğu ben alıyorum Eğer bu
harekatta başarısız olursak önce siz
beni atarsınız diyor şimdi böyle bir
cesarete gerçekten bir urgan atmak Acaba
mümkün müdür bir sonuç verir mi
Atatürk'ü anlayabilmek için napolyon'u
bilmek büyük kartacalı hükümdar Hani
balı bilmek Atatürk'ü anlamak için
bu timurleng bilmek sezar'ı bilmek Hz
Muhammed'i bilmek gerekir Bakın bu
tarafı hiç konuşulmaz ama Atatürk
hakkında yazılan hatıralarından pek
çoğunda Hz Muhammed'e olağanüstü Atıf
vardır Atatürk Hz Muhammed sadece bir
manevi önderi olarak bir peygamber
olarak görmez aynı zamanda büyük bir
devrimci olarak görür ve bunu defalarca
da tekrarlanmıştır Bedir savaşını
tarihteki en büyük Zafer olarak görür
böyle bir stratejik ve taktik daha asla
bir daha tekrarla namazlar Hatta Hz
Muhammed'in büyük bir devrimci olarak
bu Şahin ve kötücül bir toplumdan bir
devlet yaratma ülküsünün kendisine amaç
edinmiştir bu kısmından hiç bahsetmez
mesela Hatta Eğer siyasi kanadı böyle
ikiye ayırırsak her iki tarafta
enteresan bir şekilde bahsetmez Atatürk
hakkında bildiğinizi düşündüğünüz
şeylerin çoğu eksiktir ya fazladır ya da
ona ait değildir enteresan bir şekilde
sözünü ettiğim şey o Atatürk
pedagojisine büyük hatalar yapıyoruz ve
çocukları ve gençleri özellikle en çok
Umuda ihtiyacınız olduğu zaman da bence
çok büyük haksızlık yapıyoruz
Atatürk bunun yanında tarih bilinci çok
yüksek birisin tarih adeta bir geçmiş
bilim olarak değil gelecek bilimi olarak
algılayan birisinden söz ediyoruz
Aslında hali kafasında Hayriye dikkat
edin tarihi yeniden yorumlayarak dünya
inceleyen sayısının Neredeyse en
tepesine çıktı atatürk'te ki tarih
bilinci yer bizim Milli Eğitim Bakanlığı
politikasında yıllardır uygulanan Sayın
savaşları sadece tarihi tarihlerden
ibadet değil de tarih bilinci oturup da
anlayabilecek gelecek kurma yönünde çok
daha fazla şanslı olacaktık Atatürk
kendisini mesela Biraz önce sözünü
ettiğim büyük kart acılı hükümdar
hayvanın devamlı olarak kabul eder çünkü
hani bi' özelliği nedir
emperyalizme karşı ilk büyük savaşı
gerçekleştirmiş komutandır her ne kadar
başarısız olsa bile Roma'yı büyük
Roma'yı yıllarca titreten bu komutan Alp
dağlarını 36 tane fiille dağlardan aşağı
doğru fiilleri indirerek baskınla mesela
Alp dağlarını geçmiştir şimdi Atatürk'ün
cesaretinden söz ettim hanibal Alp
dağlarını geçecek dağlardan fiillerle
aşağı inecek de Anadolu dağlarından Türk
süvarileri bu baskın yapamayacak mı bu
hem oradan feyz alıp hem de aynı zamanda
tarihi bir bilinçle okuyan bu karakter
aynı zamanda Kurtuluş Savaşı'nın en
çetrefilli dönemlerinde Hani Barın
Gebze'deki mezarının bulunmasını Vasiyet
eder Hatta mezar bulunduğu bulunmadığını
soru işaretidir ama onun vasiyetini
ilişki 1981 yılında bugün Gebze'deki
TÜBİTAK Kampüsü içerisinde bir hani var
heykeli bulunur Anıtı bulunmuş Sadece bu
da değil mesela çok alakasız gibi
görünse bile Atatürk büyük Truvalı
hükümdar Hector hayranıdır ve hep Tura
defalarca referans verir Bunun aynısını
kim de görürüz Arkadaşlar Fatih Sultan
Mehmet de görürüz bir başka büyük
komutan Fatih Sultan Mehmet'e görürüz
Mora seferinden dönerken Atina'da
akropolisin üzerine çıkıp Truva Sen
intikamını direklerden aldım diyebilecek
kadar bu tarih bilincine sahip bir başka
komutan Fatih Sultan Mehmet'i
Atatürk'ten Atatürk'ü Fatih Sultan
Mehmet'ten ayrılmak gibi bir şey mümkün
değildir Bunlar eşitliğin iki ucu
gibidir diye düşünebilirsiniz Ancak bunu
bütüncül kavradığı mı zaman tarih
bilincine yerlerini oturtabiliriz
Atatürk aynı zamanda büyük bir halk
insanıdır halkın hep içindedir kimsenin
olmadığı kadar halkın içindedir bir
Ahmet Hidayet reel anlatır 1924 Erzurum
ve Pasinler depreminde sahayı
dolaşıyorken Hatta bilekten filmi vardır
biraz o filmin canlandırması dır o
sahnenin
gerçekten İzbe yıkılmış köylerin
arasında perişan duran bir köylünün
yanına gider köylüye sorar babader
depremde kaybın büyük mü adam bu
konuşmakta biraz çekilir çekildiğini
görünce daha yumuşak bir ses tonuyla
hükümetinden istediğim bir şey var mıdır
yapabileceğimiz bir şey var mıdır dar
adam öyle Kürt şivesiyle yarım yamalak
ufak kısık bir sesle bev Allah'a padişah
bilirler bunun Zehra atatürkçüler ve
belki Baba artık padişah Yok siz onu
kaldırmadınız mı Sen söyle Devleti'nden
istediğim bir şey var mıdır diye sorar
adam valla padişah bir lafını tekrarla
dıktan sonra sağında Duran kaymakama
döner ve der ki Kaymakam devrimi ya
yapmamışsınız var bunun üzerine görevini
yapmış edasıyla ağırbaşlı bir şekilde
Atatürk'e dönüp konuşan genç tahirat
memuru der ki paşam der genelgeyi bütün
köylere yolladılar bunun üzerine
Atatürk'ün suratı yüzü fırtınaya tutulur
ve şunu söyler oğlum der Devrim
genelgeyle olmaz Devrim inanmakla olur o
zaman sorarım ya bu kadar inanmış bir
zihninde onun takipçilerin acaba Zihnine
pranga vurmak ya da heykeline urgan
atmak Acaba mümkün müdür diye sorduğunda
cevabını hepimiz biliyoruz O anlatılacak
o kadar çok elektrot vardır ki on
yıllardır Laiklik nedir meselesini çözen
etmişizdir bunu da kılıçalipaşa anlatır
Kılıç Ali'nin muhteşem birlikte Dur bir
gün meclisin çok tartışmalı ortamında
zamanın dinle mallarından biri mecliste
kürsüye çıkar ve alaycı bir tavırla bir
konuşma yapar konuşmanın gözünde kabaca
söyle söyler ya sürekli laiklik laiklik
diyorsunuz da ne menem şeydir bileklikli
anlatın da bunu bilelim diye tüm Meclisi
alay eder riyaset makamında olan oturan
Mustafa Kemal dayanamaz Hoca'ya doğru
döner Hocalar çok basit Anlamak mümkün
ben sana şöyle anlatayım laiklik adam
olmaktır
Ama gerçekten muhteşem bir örnek tut ben
bileyim bu kadar güzel anlatıldığını hiç
görmedim
Atatürk aynı zamanda
tarih bilincinin
yüksek derinlikli o nitelikler zekâsının
yanında her daim Mimar düşünebilen zarif
düşünebilen de bir adamdır ve adeta
çağları Aşan Bir fikri aynı zamanda
Atatürk'e fihrist demek bir yanılgı
olmaz çünkü Atatürk ilişkin anlattığımız
anektodlar a bakıldığında Aslında bugün
çokça konuştuğumuz yetişkin eğitiminde
pek söz konusu ettiğimiz işte psikolojik
dirençlilik Çevik ve esnek zeka
motivasyon sürdürülebilirlik karar
bilimi stratejik bir laflar disiplinler
var ya o disiplinin her birine ilişkin
bir adet Türk elektrotu bulmak mümkündür
Peki dip toplamda tam olarak ne
olmaktadır ki bu kadar açık bir durum
varken yani her bir Türk ferdinin bu
Atatürk'e bu ülkede Çünkü Atatürk'ün
Cumhuriyeti'nde yaşıyoruz ve ilelebet
öyle yaşayacağız Umudumuz hayaliniz ve
beklentimiz inandığımız şey bu
Atatürk'ün bu kadar tartışma konusu
olması gerçekten anlaşılır olmaktan çok
uzak ancak kötücül bir zihnin ürünüdür
Atatürk'ün siyasi görüş değildir Atatürk
siyasetin Kendisi de değildir Atatürk
siyaseti ve siyasetin kendisinin
getirdiği bütün O tip çevre alanların
üstünde bir karakterdir kendisine bu
durumu defalarca ifade eder Tanrı
Ömer'in Suphi Tanrıöver en çok güzel bir
açıklaması vardır Atatürk gelişim kendi
ağzından naklettiği bir anekdotu bu
bence günümüzü de aydınlatan bir anekdot
Atatürk der ki her iki tane Atatürk
vardır bir tanesi benim et ve kan olan
Atatürk bunu unutun ikinci Atatürk ise
ben olarak İfade edemeyeceğim bir
Atatürk obiziz o Sizsiniz Anadolu'nun
her köşesinde gelişme aydınlık ve Çağdaş
muasır medeniyetler seviyesine ulaşma
arzusuyla tutuşan bu yolda benimle yola
çıkan ve çıktıkları yolda beni
açmalarını bu mutlaka Elzem gördüğüm
Atatürk asla Türk budur onu anladığınız
ve onu duymadınız sürece Cumhuriyeti
ilelebet Payidar olacaktır notuyla
Aslında geleceğe ilişkin çok önemli bir
vurgu yapar O yüzden şaşırıyorum benim
bilim çalışıyorum biliyorsunuz Ben beyin
bilimde çokça sözünü ettiğimiz
bir laf vardır insanlar sonsuz derecede
karmaşık ilginç sinema çıktıları son
derece iptidaiye olabilir deriz Biz Ben
diyorum ki vücutta iki tane iki loplu
organ var bir tanesi beyin Sen sol Ben
isabion diğer iki loplu organın üzerinde
oturuyorsun şu an nedense zaman zaman
beyni kullanmaktansa diğer lokma düşünme
eğiliminde oluyoruz Bence birçok şeyin
sebebi bu hatta bir insanda minimum 5
tane duyu organı varken her şeytandan
anlama konusunda da gerçekten çok mavis
Bu da bir önceki sözün tamamlayıcısı
olarak kabul edin ama Yılmak yok ama
Yılmak yok bütün bu menhus olaylarda her
defasında bir kez daha görüyoruz ki
Aslında bu Cumhuriyet Atatürk'ün
cesaretine Atatürk'ün ferasetine
Atatürk'ün ilerleme arzusuna Atatürk'ün
psikolojik dirençliliği ne Atatürk'ün
Çevik ve esnek zihinde sahip bir
Cumhuriyet O yüzden bütün bu değerleri
Bunlar bizim yumuşak güç unsurlarını
birbirinden ayrılmadan yerinden
ayrılmadan geleceği koşturmak bizim
görevimiz ben var yani gönülden ve
kalpten bunun olabileceğine inanıyorum
ve her daim Atatürk'le birlikte kalın
diyorum
[Müzik]